[Music]
surreal more than anything else feeling
like i was in a dream i mean these
movies are
so big
um the sets are so big the costumes are
incredible um feels like you're inside a
tv screen
and then there's the added part where
you can't talk about it so at the end of
your day it's not like you can like call
your mom and be like you'll never
believe what i did today so you just
kind of delete it so it feels like
you're walking into a dream really
[Music]
i guess pretty good
i just saw it the other day and yeah
there's a lot of people going to dust
that's pretty sad because before you
didn't have me
yeah yeah you didn't that's good wow so
i guess i'm pretty good about
it it's challenging because there are so
many characters but you know something
that we learned on captain america civil
war joe and i
we that movie was the first movie that
we did that had a really large number of
characters in it and what we realized as
we were crafting that movie was that it
doesn't it doesn't necessarily matter
how much screen time the character has
it's just what you do with it you know
there's characters in civil war for
instance that um like spider-man or
ant-man they didn't have a lot of screen
time in that movie but they were able to
make a big impact i think audiences were
really able to enjoy and get a lot out
of their time on screen so that's really
how we try to to balance and shape the
movie is like we make sure that all the
time that each character has is very
meaningful and memorable and exciting
i mean i know because this is it this is
everything we've got is in this um
there'll probably be
a
you know a handful of deleted scenes on
the dvd but it's not many i mean we
really we put everything uh all the
stories in there
[Music]
we are done for now we don't have any i
mean one of the creative upsides i think
in terms of how we approached this movie
is we weren't thinking about the future
there's no future for us right now in
the mcu and the story was since set
intended to be a conclusion as opposed
to a setup to something coming in the
future but we love marvel we love these
stories we love these characters we've
had the greatest run for the past seven
years making these four movies so in
with the right material joe and i would
certainly do another marvel
i'm giving that one a 10.
have you worn that one i really like it
yeah
i love it
it's a nice little mini dress with a
smudging plunging neckline and a belt
and a boot but yeah chic that's pretty
pretty that's that's my favorite one
okay so this is actually hawkeye in the
1990s
nice headpiece
i'm gonna go with eight for that one
okay
[Music]
oh man i mean all every time you hang
out with that guy that guy is um
it's not even too much
i've had like sit downs with him but
it's more i every time i was just
thinking about him actually before he
sat down
he's like wow i miss him and he's got
such a
like a cheeky smile on his face always a
very very smart guy
but he's just got a youthful spirit
um until his last moments you know
he's always he's the fire in his heart
and
he's a cowboy and
which is just he's in his body with
fortitude and strength and he always had
a smile on his face and uh his he had a
light lightness to him
that was um
infectious
and that's what every experience i've
had with him oh it's just such a
wonderful
giving awful man
i just had one experience but i'm so
grateful to have had that one
it's one of the many things that i think
about
about this entrance into this this
marvel universe that i had the
opportunity to have a cameo time with
him
yeah i mean i just think it's his energy
on set whenever when we hear his voice
and just like turn everyone into kids
again i think
you know there's a lot of movie stars
that work on these movies but
you know there's more energy and
excitement when stan was on scene than
anybody
i remember our first cameo with
with stan was on civil uh winter soldier
and i remember him coming to set that
day it was the first time we met him and
just the um
just having that first impression of him
was so amazing he the way he came on the
set which is he just lit up the room and
he the energy that he brought was
amazing for his age
uh and i think i was so impressed with
his level of enthusiasm that he still
was so passionate and excited to be do
to be telling these stories uh that that
really stuck struck me and stuck with me